qui sera le plus proche des jeunes
familles libéraux et conservateurs
misent sur la même recette est la même
clientèle
pas seulement dans vos images mais dans
les programmes aussi les nouveaux
gouvernements constructeur va modifier
cette résistance pour assurer que les
acheteurs première voire et n'hypothèque
faciliter l'achat d'une première maison
allègements fiscaux dans la première
tranche de revenus exemptions d'impôts
pour les nouveaux parents conservateurs
et libéraux ont multiplié les promesses
similaires ces derniers jours elle
touche il accuse justin trudeau de
plagiat le chef libéral tente de marquer
les différences
la vraie différence entre les
conservateurs et libéraux c'est que
notre approche n'aide pas les mieux
nantis
pour le chef du npd libéral ou
conservateur c'est du pareil au même
les deux coupes les services les deux
travaillent pour les plus riches
le chef libéral mis sur une autre
tactique pour se distinguer de son
adversaire conservateur jouer sur
l'impopularité du premier ministre
ontarien d'oxford qui voulez-vous voir
négocier avec dale ford dans ce point de
presse où il s'engageait à améliorer
l'accès aux soins de santé au pays
justin trudeau a prononcé son nom
une quinzaine de fois d'hagfors d'iphone
d'ipod d'iphone d'alfort tape fort à
gauche il répond en citant d'autres
politiciens impopulaire en ontario et
même bilan pour justin trudeau et elles
suivent le même temps à force de jouer
sur le même terrain de mêler les acteurs
provinciaux et fédéraux les parties
risque-t-il d'alimenter une certaine
confusion chez les électeurs les débats
au début du mois d'octobre seront
peut-être l'occasion pour les canadiens
d'avoir un portrait plus claire de ce
qu'est défendre les chefs ici louis but
- radio-canada bon